great cook and great chef certainly the
the quick itself or great chef in the in
in some restaurant very often don't have
that much to do with the cooking anymore
you go to the Waldorf Astoria for
example than the chef we love to content
with several banquet of a thousand
fifteen hundred people so it will go
organized of course work out is menu
taste here and there but that's about it
if you want to make a distinction
between in a sense a tankful chef and a
skillet chef you know and the skillet
chef being someone we have a small
restaurant or someone like Thomas Keller
here at and will be behind the stove
cooking cooking day after day you know
morning after morning so that's really
someone involved in the cooking itself
both of those are chef you know my
definition I am NOT a chef unless I work
in a professional kitchen with other
people who are working for me
to M code the chef which is the chief in
France
to run that kitchen when I go back at
home I'm the cook my work is the chef
and how it's different so many young
Chefs call me now and it exciting with
what they are doing I mean even at the
French Culinary Institute where I teach
here in New York I am amazed by those
young chef what they can do in six
months of the program which is 600 and
some hours what they can do at the end
of those 600 hours I would never have
been able to do that after three years
of apprenticeship even after five years
we learn in a totally different way when
I was a child we stole the trade we
didn't learn it that is you would ask
the chef what is this and it would
answer some type of stupidity you know
you you say what if that sauce call is
say a sauce not which means nothing
wrong it would never tell you how to do
anything and one day we tell you
tomorrow you start at the stove you say
me I so you learn to a type of osmosis
looking and they watch really you knew
how to do it
you become very proficient with your
hand because there was a lot of
technique and a lot of manual work to do
shopping slicing man singing and so
forth cleaning up the kitchen and so
forth now in a place like for example at
the French Culinary Institute and most
of the school it cost first a fortune so
you cater to the people you show them
you explain and all that meaning that
they learn much much faster however they
are not quite as proficient with their
hand as we would have been as we were
you know when I was an apprentice it was
a different type of learning learning
way you know Authority is really
important just because like any any type
of manual trade you have to learn the
technique you have to be a good
technician and this is what I
concentrate on on my teaching in the
technique you know and think which are
very often difficult to explain in world
you know that are very visual I mean
from chucking an oyster to doing a
caramel cage or boning our chicken or
doing an omelet and so forth this is
technique that you have to repeat and
repeat and repeat and repeat so much
that by the time you absorb them that
you can afford to forget them and then
you can afford to think in terms of what
the vegetable I'll do maybe the texture
will go well with that the color will go
well with that we also say that you
think in terms of the future the dish
and your hand work automatically and
prepare those things as long as you are
totally updated you know if you want by
the slicing of an onion and someone come
around and say do you have any parsley
here I said don't disturb me because you
are working on that kind of menial task
of slicing the onion you cannot move
forward you have to get rid of that and
by getting rid of that you have to
practice practice practice it enough so
you cannot afford to forget it just like
if you're a painter you know you work
two or three years in a studio and you
learn now to the law of perspective and
you learn how to mix yellow and blue to
do green and you know you can do that
with your thumb or with a spatula and
all that so you kind of learn the trick
of the trade meaning that after three
years you can stand outside and you can
do one
after another does that make you a great
artist no you're a good technician
that's what you have well in the kitchen
likewise you know you have to become a
good technician and I'm sure a surgeon
as well Adam Mason first up to become
good technician before they move forward
you know behind the technique itself
that is the knowledge of whatever trade
it is then it did of course talent and
there is talent there is also someone
the willingness of doing this and you
have to keep at it and there is a
certain discipline involved in that so
the discipline as long as with the
talent with the proper technique with
the certain openness to learn with other
people eventually you reach to a to a
certain level where you can express
yourself because in the kitchen
certainly all you have to say is yes
chef Allen apprentice that's about it
and because the chef is not going to ask
you your opinion you go work at Danielle
or jean-jacques in New York or any of
the great restaurant you are going to do
what the chef won there because the
kitchen has been set up by someone with
a great chef another vision of the way
the food should be so your lair to learn
so you absorb and you learn and then you
charge a year later work with someone
else we may not do exactly we probably
will not do the same thing in the same
manner so you learn another way another
point of view another way of looking at
thing and after you do that for a number
of years 7 8 10 years then you have
absorbed that enormous amount of
material which you kind of regurgitate
if you want with for the path but you do
is get that through your own sense of
aesthetic through your own sense of ID
and then you start creating your own
type of cuisine with your own idea